e
e e
yeah yes we are ready um so just just
before we get started I I have uh some
suggested language that I just asked
Jennifer to go make copies so we can all
so we would all we would all have it um
so this is uh the committee of
conference on uh uh House Bill
1069 um thank you all for coming
appreciate that um there were um as as
I've sort of looked at this I I think
there are there are sort of two issues
one is is kind of a narrow fix that I
think um I I think I hope will be
non-controversial the other is a little
bit broader um that
I personally I'm kind of agnostic on but
I can see the arguments on both sides
and maybe we you know we should have a
discussion of the little broader one but
um uh first uh the two things that um
were the Where were the U basic reason
for our the house requesting a committee
of conference were um there is language
in the Senate version of the bill um
that that we were
concerned uh could could um and it's the
the language I'm referring to uh says
and I'm quoting here no charge shall be
made for records delivered
electronically
and I think what this what the Senate
intended by that and actually the house
has so much similar language um is that
you meant by that no charge shall be
made for clicking the send button and
having it delivered um and we don't have
we're completely in agreement with that
as I said there's sort of similar
language in in the house version what we
were concerned about is
arguably that could be
read would you mind Jen could you would
you mind just giving it to the all the
members of the great thank you very
much um arguably that could be read to
mean no no charge can be made for
records delivered electronically that
that includes not only hitting the send
button but any of the prior work of of
in other words if the records are
delivered electronically then there can
be no charge even if it would the the
town you know were faced with more than
250 emails and not more than 250
electronic communications which was the
subject of a,2 so we were concerned that
it this could be could be read as
conflicting with a th000 with house bill
,000 2 so a proposed
change that I have't I've I've asked
that this be passed around i' I've
worked off the Senate uh version of 1069
with your
Amendment
um where is it
1966 s um so what what I would propose
to change there is
on uh
page two of of that amendment in section
in section four of the bill uh Roman
numeral 5- a parenthesis B so I changed
the language in the last sentence to say
no charge shall be made for the delivery
of Records electronically comma but a
reasonable charge may be made for the
time necessary to process the request if
authorized by this chapter and I have to
I had to word it that way because we
couldn't say the specific section
because the governor hasn't signed a
1002 yet and so it's not really law
right now so that's why I worded it that
way um so that would take care of I
think that would take care of that issue
it would make it clear that what we're
saying you you can't you can't charge
for the electronic delivery delivery
being a sort of you know that what we
mean by that is pressing the send button
you can't charge for that um but if
there's if if it meets the requirements
of
a,2 that is it's more than 250
electronic communications or whatever
you could charge for the time necessary
to do
that Mr chairman um you're talking about
the time
to put everything together versus
because you're talking here about the
electronic delivery but now you're
talking about the work that it's taking
okay
exactly okay do you have language that
speaks to that I I do so I what I said
is um okay well the delivery no no
charge should be made for the delivery
of Records electronically but a
reasonable charge may be made for the
time necessary to process the request if
authorized by this chapter and so that
would be that would you know by if
authorized by this chapter really means
if 1,2 would allow it right I understand
that um okay I'm the only thing I'm
concerned about and it's anything that
has to do with
91a there are a lot of people that
follow 91a they they're very uh
concerned about changes and I'm I'm just
concerned about what is a reasonable
charge um and
usually it's laid out when you're doing
it by paper there's a cost per page but
what is a reasonable charge here because
in 2000 at
10002 they um you could do the 250
requests it doesn't cost you anything
but now you're instituting a reasonable
charge gosh and I'm concerned that
they're going to be a little in conflict
and in when we had the public care on
one um on this on the other Bill one2 a
lot of people were concerned about cost
if there were any cost and they get
those 250 for free but now you're saying
here if uh if it's electronic they're
going to be charged what is considered
to be a reasonable cost well you know so
I mean maybe would it does it help if I
take out the word reasonable in other
words what I the only thing I meant to
say by that is is the the really I think
the key the key point is the last words
if authorized by this chapter and what
that in other words what that is really
what that means is it's authorized by
this chapter only if it meets the
requirements of a,2 okay so so if I yeah
I I would just bring up um I've been in
communication with um my town manager
they just
recently um completed a c a request one
request that
was an unbelievable amount it cost them
$25,000 to produce what this person
asked for and that was just one request
um in two
one2 that's free that doesn't cost
anything so I'm concerned that this is
going to conflict it was all electronic
all the information was submitted uh
electronically back to the person
so I I'm just concerned that we're doing
something here that maybe we need to be
a little concerned about yeah well you
know what so if in other words if if you
I think if your concern was that by put
by having the word reasonable in there
that could mean in other words that that
somehow a somebody a court or whatever
could find that a charge was reasonable
even if it didn't meet the criteria of
a,2 I I see what you're saying and so
what if we just took the word reasonable
out so it would say but a charge may be
made uh for the time necessary to
process the request if authorized by
this chapter which that really means is
if authorized by a,2 I quite frankly I
wouldn't my my problem is not with
reasonable it's with
charge um and I don't know if that's
going to if that's going to conflict
because um I think if you're going to
charge it should should be something
reasonable but what is what what do you
consider to be reasonable and that's
where you're going to run into issues
because everyone is going to look each
each Community could decide what
unreasonable is there's no one
particular standard other than they may
charge if they so choose to and I can
pretty well but isn't the key here if
authorized by this chapter so the only
and the only authorization the chapter
is
a,2 right and that is after
250 so it is going beyond the
$250 a 250 requests so I I don't feel
comfortable with this again because
right to know is very tenuous and people
get really upset about it this is
something new um so I think we can
continue to have a discussion about it
but um
sure I'm just concerned representative
tur and then representative Smith oh I'm
sorry uh yeah so just looking at this um
one thought is I I think the real
question for me or problem with this for
me is the word time because time is what
was taken out of 102 from its original
form versus what past eventually was on
a per reccord basis and that's the part
that I think worries me about
this kind of changes my understanding is
when we say you know you know request
authorized by this chapter 102 doesn't
really have a Time component in it
anymore so I was thinking since this is
really B and correct me if a different
understanding
B um 5ab is basically talking about the
process of delivering the thing not the
process of producing the the record and
so I was thinking if we just basically
sort of said clarified that no delivery
charge would be made and then leave the
other parts out because 102 sort of
takes care of that so I don't know what
folks think of that but I I I worry
about putting too much language in here
and sort of relying on the passage of
102 to to sort of clean it up on the
back end yeah so I'm sorry
representative Smith uh
thank you Mr chair I'm having a a funny
kind of problem in terms of what hat I
should be wearing I I know that I'm here
to um support the house
position uh as compared with the Senate
position and
um I this is new this language is new I
hadn't seen it before um as an
alternative to the house position but to
me
um the the
problem the problem isn't the word
reasonable the problem is the word
charge and um one hopes that we would
never consider charging anything that
wasn't reasonable we would never do a
thing like that never never um and I
don't understand how this helps support
the house position and at the same time
bring us closer to being able to reach
accommodation with the Senate um am I
missing something
here so I I guess what I would say is
this so Eric are you may maybe your
language is does the trick in other
words you you would say
no no delivery charge shall be made for
records produced electronically does
that does that with with putting aside
the concerns that representative Smith
had for a moment do would that would
that solve your issue U well thank you
Mr chairman
um it's it's already there all we did in
the Senate was we just took the language
that you sent us and we just
reconfigured it a little bit right um
and so it already says no charge shall
be made for records deliver
electronically I think that's very
clear um it because you're talking about
the delivery it's it is hitting that
send button to somebody who requested
the information well see but you know
what the pro I mean that's
certainly one reasonable interpretation
of it and that's and you know that's
what as I said before I think that we we
sort of assume that's what you meant but
that's not the only interpretation you
could read no charge shall be made for
records delivered electronically you
could read that to mean if the records
are sent by hitting the send button no
charge can be made for those records no
matter what the the prior circumstances
were about getting the information in
other words even if it is more than 250
emails whereas I think Eric Eric we
restructured the language just a little
bit but I think can you say can you read
it was it was just to clarify the
difference between the two
interpretations that I think uh uh
representative Lynn is talk chairman
Lynn is talking about um basically by
adding the word delivery it takes the
ambiguity out because the way it's
written now it could sound like it could
override 102 which does allow for
charges if you exceed the 250 records so
by saying delivery it sort of makes this
paragraph B just about you know the
difference between post postage versus
there's no postage if you're if you're
hitting the send button so it's just a
one word it would be just a onew change
and and I would hope not not bring in
those questions about reasonableness and
and time you know and the other stuff
that sort of bogged down for a while 102
if I may Mr chair I guess I guess the
the issue is to put these uh object is
delivery not records so by I as I
understand it um to
move shall be made four and the four the
object of four is delivery not records
so it's really just changing records and
swapping records and
delivery is that what is that well I you
know what I think in other words I I I
think that the way rep representative
tur phrased it um does do that yeah you
right no in other words no delivery if
you if you say it if you refer to it as
delivery charge it's a specific kind of
charge a charge for delivery so no
delivery charge shall be made for
records produced electronically that
would that would be my thought I I think
that I mean I'm I'm perfectly
comfortable with that if everybody else
is and represent Smith I you you may I
realize you may not be but so if if you
have further comment on
that have a further comment on that
particularly I have to admit that I'm a
product of progressive education so
parts of speech I'm not so you know good
at um I barely know a subject from a
predicate so I look to the senator as
being far superior to me in in her
educational
ability um
uh but um I I would like to ask Senator
Carson I'm delighted to sit here with
you we haven't sat together in a long
time um about your
$25,000 figure because I'm curious
about what caused that
$25,000 and wonder and I've had this
discussion over these
bills quite a bit including with the
municipal Association and others about
why H how how those charges get so high
and is it that immediately an attorney
is called in and hired not someone on
staff to do what one might think would
be routine work uh you know what
composes that comprises that
25,000 from what I've Been Told um it is
an individual who made the request going
back to
2017 of all police activity in the town
of
London so as you can imagine anybody who
had any contact with the police you've
got to redact their names you've got to
go through all of that and I I just you
look at the volume of the paperwork that
had to have been gone through in order
to do that um do you know if anybody
picked up the phone and said what do you
need this information for I don't
believe that you can ask them they they
make the request and you have to you
have to do what they give them what
they've asked for you don't get to
qualify it you don't need you I I mean
in fact I was having a conversation with
somebody that maybe in the next step of
reforming and that's what we're trying
to do here of um article 91a is to
create that the ability for the
municipality to reach out and said you
know hey what what is it exactly that
you're looking for um you have some
people that this is what I want and I
want it all but they really don't have
the ability I we do have the right to
know on budsman I don't know um uh it's
due to for a while go out in to in
2025 and I think next year would be a
good time to look at it it'll be a
budget year whether or not we want to
extend that from what I understand he uh
he does a lot of things for people they
do call them but there's got to be a
point where there can be some sort of
negotiation between an individual and a
municipality over the volume of what
someone is looking for and you know it
can be done in a way well you know we
want to answer your request can you
please you know narrow it down for us
what exactly are you looking for but
from what I understand sometimes that
happens but sometimes it doesn't well
you know just just on that point I mean
we there is language now in
A2 y that says it it's not exactly as
strong as you you suggest but it says
that the the town can sort of if uh have
some discussion with the requester about
um what you know sort of what are you
looking for in an effort to try to
narrow the request which I think is a
good thing yeah I I do too because um
that was only one of the requests um
we've had another one that's cost and
it's been a series of requests that have
cost the town this was last year I
believe in um September October I was
told uh
$35,000 and so these things add up after
a while and um this this is taxpayer
money this is not money that you know a
municipality is hidden away in a room
someplace this is all the taxpayers are
paying for it and I think when you have
small requests there most certainly
please you know give them what they want
but when You' get these huge requests I
it becomes a burden on the municipality
and it causes uh you know t a good
amount of taxpayer dollars to be used so
um you have to honor that it is in our
constitution but I do think that um you
know there there should be a way for the
municipality and the individual who's
the requester to have a conversation
about what are you looking for can we
help you narrow this down that helps you
that helps me or the municipality get
through this process sooner and I think
that's something that we can try to do I
agree I agree with so let me go back to
them qu is would everybody be
comfortable if we change
if we took the Senate version of this
and on
lines 29 and 30 we changed the language
to read no delivery charge shall be made
for records produced
electronically everybody all right with
that I can't agree to that at this point
um I'm increasingly concerned with all
the corresponden I'm getting from um
Town manager
just got one handed to me a few minutes
ago from the Hudson police chief um
phone calls that I've gotten from local
officials I think that we are opening up
a Pandora's Box I know the house of
passed a bill Senate passed a bill um I
don't know that we know the
ramifications and the cost of this and
I'm not sure that I'm going to be able
to agree to um
this I do like the fact that
on um representative Lynn online 23 that
you have um changed from person to
member of the media or somebody with a
New Hampshire address but I I I'm not
sure that I'm ready to say this is a
good idea
to so I guess
I mean so
the I'm just wondering if if we I guess
the thing I'm I'm not sure I understand
though Senator is this if we left the
language the way it is in the Senate
Amendment right what I mean what what do
you think that means then in terms of
electronic um of of what happens when
records are delivered electronically
that that's the thing I'm not clear that
I if I
understand could could I could I ask a
question of the president sure um are
you
saying
that you could not support if it came to
pass that the house decided to
accept the Senate
version as it as you approved it that
you are not prepared to accept
that I'm saying that I am increasingly
concerned with all the correspondents
I've had since we passed this version
two weeks ago that
um I am increasingly concerned with
opening up a Pandora's Box for local
officials um without knowing the
ramifications or the cost because of you
know some of the correspondents I've
received and I think it was the town of
Tilton talked to me a former state
senator who's the town manager now um
request that was 400 hours and then the
person didn't even um pick up the
information so I just I don't know this
is so Senator inly a concern okay so
Senator Bradley what you're saying is
despite my
naive no one naive here oh yes my naive
understanding that the house has a
position that the house conferees are
presenting and the Senate has a position
that the Senate conf that you are not
supporting the Senate because of some of
the correspondence that I've received
since the Senate voted on this a couple
of weeks ago I thank you that's very
important saying absolutely no never but
I I think that some of the concerns that
local officials have raised have not
been addressed in either version so you
know what can I Senator I'll get you
just in just one sec but Senator Bradley
the thing I'm
having that I'm having some difficulty
with is is this if as representative
Smith pointed out I mean suggested if
the house were to Simply concur with the
Senate
Amendment and if
my interpretation of the current
language on lines 29 and 30
is is
correct then at least one arguable
interpretation of that of that version
would be no charge should be made for
records delivered electronically if that
can be interpreted and I think it could
be to say if the records are delivered
electronically there can be no charge
even if it's more than 250 electronic
communication or whatever I mean I I
guess the thing I'm to the extent that
your concern is is imposed closing and
undo burden on towns it would seem to me
that that this could be read the Senate
version right now could be read to mean
it's more of a burden on towns because
they can't charge at all I suspect you
are correct with that so that I mean
there's the conundrum that's so I mean I
but I guess I I mean
that's the Senate has I mean with with
with differeny you're having a a a
different view I understand but the
Senate has passed this so if if I may um
that language is language that we agreed
from the house the only difference here
is the change of the word from P from
citizen to person that's the only change
this this is all the language that we
got from the house we just restructured
it but it's all there the only
difference and I see where there would
be angst with changing it from citizen
to person because when you talk about
citizen you're talking about citizen of
the State of New Hampshire person it
leaves It Wide Open for anybody and
that's the emails that I have been
getting that people are concerned that
this is way too open anybody from any
place in the
world can request um these records and
there's a reason reason why well I'll
tell you why we did that um there's two
reasons one is in regards to a case
currently that's going on in Rochester
where the uh newspaper editor lives in
Maine and familiar with the he's trying
to get the request he writes his
newspaper is in Rochester they will not
honor his 91a request because he is not
a citizen of the State of New Hampshire
he lives in MA that's one reason the
other reason is we have people that live
here in our here in our state that are
here legally they're immigrants here
legally that pay taxes to the state of
New Hampshire they pay Municipal Taxes
but they're not
citizens so they can't make a 91a
request if it if you're going to Define
citizens of the state they're not IL
legal they're not citizens yet they're
here legally they're doing everything
right they're doing the right
thing but by using the word citizen they
can't they just can't they can't it
doesn't apply oh even though they're
taxpayers yes Senator I'm sorry um no
thank you um I appreciate it and I I do
understand it is an interesting position
to be in when we do wear different hats
and I am here um to represent the
position of the Senate and um
I I am very supportive of the right to
know and want to make sure that people
have access to it I do like the steps
that have been suggested to put some um
I don't want to use the word guardrails
but nothing else is coming to mind but
to put some conditions that are
appropriate on it so that we don't run
into the issues that uh Senator Bradley
described that I mean it is unduly
burdensome to some uh towns and I
believe that language is that language
undo burden is that in that is that is
in the yes that is in the um yes um but
Mr chairman can you reference um if
House Bill one is it one2 becomes law um
is it make it conditional upon the
passage of that particular
legislation and that could be a way to
tie them together
I I don't know I mean can I guess we can
we do that can we Jennifer can we make
it reference can we say you know no no
charge no delivery charge shall be made
uh for
records uh um but other charges may be
may be allowed per uh if the statute
for the section like this
to
h2w then this section would be enacted I
think without CC that they could
structure something like
that I believe that's not uncommon Mr
chair um where um we do refer to other
legislation um as a condition um we do
it I think with some
frequency I have
a I have a more basic question why did
the Senate
agree to a committee of conference if
there might be a belief in the Senate
they don't want this to go ahead is that
is that a processed question that you
don't want to address now I can
understand that we're
polite Mr President I've known you for a
long time and I know you are polite and
you are careful and you
are precise but you also don't like to
waste time
that's all I'll say so you know what can
I yes if I may um I might be able to
answer that for you um the morning um
that this came that we had to make
decisions about this I had a meeting
with um members from the municipal
Association who wanted us to do a lot
more than what this bill really
addressed we I I'm not going to say we I
said no
because with the right to know you
cannot slip anything or try to put
something through without having a
public hearing you just cannot do that
um and I just said no and then probably
within an hour I started getting emails
from municipalities saying to kill this
so um I don't agree with that kind
of things that happen um I feel that
this there is a uh a value to any bill
and it's the people that are sitting at
this table who makes the decisions I
thank you for your cander Senator I
pretty much had figured that out all by
my own self as to how we got here and
I'm very glad that you shared that with
us and it does show the difficulty that
we have as to how we make make these
decisions um and to my knowledge
actually um we weren't elected by the
municipal Association that's all I want
to say so you know what um I guess um
you know one of the things um this sort
of mels over into the the the citizen
person issue um I think it's important
to understand that the the even the
current law which says which uses the
word citizen it doesn't Define Citizen
and as far as I know there's no case law
that says citizen means a citizen of the
town or citizen means a citizen of the
state or citizen means a citizen of the
United States so um it's or the world I
suppose
so you know
it's to the extent that that we are
hearing from various and I've gotten
some of those too from municipalities
that you know the sky is falling if we
change citizen to person um apparently
you know it was the the it certainly
would be an argument that citizen means
citizen of the United States under
current law yet we haven't you know we
haven't had like a flood of you know uh
California somebody as as as my my
former colleague judge smuckler used to
say somebody Jammy surfing at midnight
in California deciding to make a request
to somewhere in New Hampshire so I'm not
I'm not sure how much of a concern that
really is but I guess
um I'm I guess I don't really un know if
if we're going to unless we unless the
theory is to
just sort of tank this whole bill and I
I I assume that you're here so you
nobody's particularly interested in
doing that um I I I think we're still
really back to this issue of what you
know what do we want to say about
delivery charges for electronic
records that's Mr chairman um if I can
suggest that we take like a five minute
recess where um the Senate can discuss
these proposed changes because I think
at this point we're just going round
sure we're just going around and around
I don't want to waste anyone's time
that's fine surek absolutely let's do
can we um meet is there a place where we
can right through here oh you're right
in there yeah right in there and I'll
make sure I turn off the uh Shi Sheriff
tier recording
device Mr chairman I heard you have all
kind of snacks back
there just Cofe okay all
e
e e
all right um so what do you have to tell
us thank you I think we're better off um
agreeing to disagree and with apologies
that um we did not have adequate time to
have a public hearing on some of the
request to uh mitigate some of the
issues in the bill with the um changes
that were asked for by the municipal
Association um Senator Carson had over
bills that came over from the house with
less time as you know senate had more
time on Senate Bill's house had more
time it just didn't happen and I think
as Senator Carson has
explained um changes to the 91a need to
be more than carefully considered and as
I said before the implications for
towns um are significant and the number
of towns that have contacted I I suspect
you folks and us too um since the Senate
passed the bill I I could not have
supported it at the time knowing the Imp
applications of it so I think all of us
are better off waiting until well I
won't be here but others will be till
next year to um move forward with it
knowing
that house bill 102 which the prime
sponsor of this bill is a co-sponsor of
um is on its way to the governor because
you passed it we passed it and um it's
on its way so so I so I'm I'm sorry
was is that are you basically saying
that the Senate's position is going to
be simply to non-c concur I I I think
that that would be the best outcome yes
okay all right no that's
uh so okay all right thank you very good
all right it's always a pleasure to see
you
representative yeah and just you know
bring this forward again next year right
when one2
ISL right right well it'll be I wonder
you know it'll be I wonder if there's a
um if if the situation in uh Rochester
will end up leading to a Supreme Court
decision on this issue that uh which may
end up the may may at least the major
issue of what is a citizen will be will
be decided and I cannot imagine that
they would say citizen means just a
citizen of the town and so so the
Rochester that Rochester newspaper can't
get the records because the owner lives
in Maine I mean I that would be
mindboggling if they were to say that I
I think anyway all right well thank you
thank you Mr chairman it's always a
pleasure to see you and here you're my
fellow Judiciary members thank you same
here thank
you e